Michael, here is a world. In fact, for the
purposes of this discussion it is the world. Okay. So
imagine the entire universe is well described by this
picture over here. Okay? Now this is called a grid
world, which is something that people in reinforcement learning
love to think about, because it's a nice approximation for
all the complexity of the entire universe. Now this particularly
world is a three by four grid. So you have
one comma one, two comma one, three comma one, four comman
one. You have one comma two, one comma three and so on
and so forth. For the purpose of this discusision we can
think of the world as being a kind of game where you
start out in state. Which we're going to call the start state.
And your able to execute actions, one of these four, up, down,
left to right and the purpose is to wonder around this
world in such a way that eventually you make it to the
goal over here, this little green spot. You see that Michael?
>> Yep.
>> And under all circumstances, you must avoid the red spot.
>> No.
>> Exactly. Now for this particular example, up
does what you think it does, down does
what you think it does, as do left and right. But if you find yourself at a
boundary, such as right, up here in thi
upper-left-hand corner, and you try to go up, you
just stay where you are. If you try to go left, you just stay where you are.
But if you go right, you do actually end up in the next square. Got it?
>> Think so.
>> Okay. Three last things. One, this little black, space here, is
a place you can't enter into, so it acts just like a
wall. This green space is the goal, and once you're there it's
over. The world is over and you get to start over again.
>> Hm.
>> And once you enter into the red spot, the world is also over and you
have to start over again. So you can't go through the red square to get to
the green square. Okay, you got it?
>> Yeah.
>> Excellent. So, here's the quiz. Given this
particular world, with the physics I just described to
you, and given these actions that you can take,
up, down, left and right, what is the shortest
sequence of actions that would get us from
the start state to the goal state? And you
can just type in the words up, down, left
and right, separated by spaces, or commas or anything
like that. Okay. [LAUGH] Say semicolons are allowed, colons are not.
>> Yeah, good. I am glad you made that distinction.
>> Well, it's an important one to make. Okay, you got it?
>> Yeah, I think so.
>> Alright, cool. So let's see what you get then. Go.